Magnus Carlson's wish came true when
asked who he wanted to face in the grand
final of the aim chess rapid Magnus had
this to say oh of course it'd be
interesting to play Wesley and that wish
was granted but not before a challenge
in the first elimination match Wesley so
took on Eduardo at terrazaga the
defining moment of Wesley's victory was
an impressive Maiden seven in the second
match it was the rising star notrebec
abdusa Torah that stood in Wesley's way
the game started off with an interesting
opening you can't keep it together after
the match Wesley had this to say on that
moment I was gonna offer him a take back
in immense time pressure Wesley
converted the first game following a
blunder by Notre back in game two Wesley
managed his time efficiently and even
with the advantage a draw was agreed
upon earning Wesley the overall win an
impressive run for Wesley from losing in
the first round to fighting through the
entire loser's bracket to the Grand
Final in anticipation of Tomorrow Wesley
had this to say matches against Magnus
you gotta have a win and that's how